[Music]  your individual life vest  is located in a pouch beneath your seat  should its use become necessary  bring the straps around your waist pull  on the loose straps  [Music]  until the vest fits snugly as we are now  demonstrating  thank you for your attention  we will be airborne shortly  we are torn apart by events i like to be  submissive  do you know what that means  put back together differently by others  why japan  sometimes being alone isn't about other  people alone is about people  be careful then how do you know that i'm  not a bad man  [Music]  i don't  yes how you know difficult to make you  happy  i think i'm destined to go nuts nobody  uses their public face  in the express sometimes the mask is  prettier than the thing behind it  i tell myself there is no happy ending  all the pieces do not fit together  perfectly  but somehow everything is beautiful  [Music]  you